[Music]
a few days ago
tom holland delivered the first picture
of him in his role as video game hero
and adventurer
nathan drake the opinions about the
outdoor outfit of the spiderman star are
mostly positive so you can
definitely look forward to perhaps more
convincing performance
as young nate of course this is a
relatively big step compared to the
video games where you always play the
much older nade
except for a few sequences it seems that
the movie will develop towards the
prequel story of the first adventures
which is why the main actor seems
unusually young nate's mentor victor
sullivan who's played by mark wahlberg
is also undergoing a rejuvenation
treatment the 49 year old recently
published a video with sully's
characteristic mustache on instagram
if you put wahlberg's appearance next to
the video game character his similarity
is
definitely evident further footage is
provided by nolan north the video game
actor of nathan drake
he recently visited the film set and had
a pleasant chat with tom holland he also
shares a book with the image of the
sailor magellan and a mysterious
artifact with his followers
we are definitely curious to see what
the uncharted team will do with the
upcoming blockbuster
and are looking forward to the estimated
release date on july 16
2021 now it's official
netflix is producing its own assassin's
creed life action series for netflix
according to an official press release
of the streaming giant the cooperation
with game developer ubisoft has only
just begun
therefore you can't expect too much
information about the cast and the story
yet
what is certain however is that the live
action series will only be the beginning
of a much larger universe
it's also clear that after the failed
assassin's creed movie from 2016 there
will be no more efforts regarding a film
as netflix also announced on twitter the
two ubisoft producers jason altman and
danielle kroenig are involved so far
much more interesting is the choice of
the showrunner of season 1
because similar to the successful
project the witcher they want to
convince the very critical gaming
community
right from the start the next release of
the franchise which comprises 11 main
games is assassin's creed
valhalla but it is not yet possible to
estimate when this series will be
released
two years ago we saw hollywood superstar
jason statham in the underwater horror
movie mech by jonas taylor
at the box office the film grossed a
respectable 530 million us dollars
as the hollywood reporter now reveals
wanna brothers is already working on a
sequel to the successful first part
rebecca director ben wheatley will
direct the second part of the film which
is based around the prehistoric shark
megalodon
it is also clear that the original
director john turtletop will no longer
be involved in the film production
although the sequel has only been
officially announced recently
mack was the most successful horror
movie of the year in 2018 which is why
the idea of a sequel
has been circulating behind the scenes
for quite some time
no matter if you liked the movie or not
at least it made horror movies about
animals acceptable again after the
sharknado franchise had moved the whole
thing
more into a self-ironic and trashy
direction for years
by the way fans of the first part can
once again look forward to the large
part of the original team
including screenwriters john and eric
hober who are back on board for the
latest ocean adventure
behind the scenes lorenzo de bonoventura
and bella avery are involved as
producers an exact release date of mac 2
is unfortunately
not yet known oscar isaac became known
to a wide audience through roles in star
wars the force awakens and x-men
apocalypse
now according to report by variety the
41 year old is about to get involved in
the new marvel series
moon knight although the commitment has
not yet been officially confirmed
given the consensus in various movie
magazines it is considered
very likely on instagram fan account
venomology published a photo montage of
isaac and the black moon knight costume
the sad look also fits the background
story of the marvel character
because mark spector moon knight's real
name was fatally injured by his partner
on
expedition in egypt and could only
escape certain death with the help of
the moon god konchu
consequently he returns to earth as
avenger of the moon god
and fights crime with rather
controversial methods
thus the character is not a typical
superhero from the mcu
instead he often has to fight with
himself and his dark side
by the way the disney plus series is to
be directed by moammadia and behind the
scenes the project is also significantly
co-developed by jeremy slater a release
of the moon knight series is
as well as an official confirmation from
marvel still awaited
fans have been preparing for quite some
time for the possibility that the
characters in the upcoming the suicide
squad may die in early screen death
in addition director james gunn
published two new covers for the empire
magazine on twitter
that show the core of the cast in all
its glory empire
also has two exclusive pictures with
various team members in the works
including polka dot man peacemaker
bloodsport and
redcatcher 2. on twitter james gunn also
provided a lot of tension because
according to his own statement he can do
whatever he wants with the characters so
whoever survives or not the dc spectacle
is entirely in control of the director
in any case we are excited and look
forward to the expected release on
august 4th
[Music]
2021
[Music]
bye